[Musique]
mêlez vous de vos affaires ce soir que
des pensées vous en frais bancaires
andré yonne ça coûte des centaines de
dollars par année les sommes que des
solutions pour économiser on l'espère
parce que ça coûte cher effectivement je
vais vous montrer tout de suite des
données de l'institut de la statistique
du québec qui ne montre à quel point les
ménages peuvent dépenser des sommes
assez impressionnante pour différents
frais financiers oui oui les frais
bancaires les frais pour les cartes de
crédit 643 dollars par année est élevé
des commissions pour actions et
obligations 198 $ par année des frais de
courtage et autres services 93 dollars
différents services financiers 171 $
pour un beau total de plus de 1100
dollars on espère effectivement pouvoir
faire baisser cette facture comment on
fait on magasine et des outils pour ça
des comparateurs de prix pour tout type
de services financiers y en a plusieurs
bon là je vous en ai nommé cap il y en
ad'autres évidemment mérite rob ruijgh
points c'est à dire est une société de
montréal en fait une entreprise de
technologie financière qui lançait
aujourd'hui son comparateur de prix pour
différents services financiers ça permet
de comparer 450 produits différents dans
nombreuses catégories vous voulez
comparer par exemple les frais pour des
cartes de crédit les comptes chèques les
comptes épargne
également le courtage en ligne les
robots conseiller l'assurance vie de
l'hypothèque des prêts personnels et
cetera on dit mais quand on choisit des
produits qui sont bien adaptés un
canadien peut économiser entre 300 et
1000 $ par année au magazine ça vaut la
peine
et quand on regarde ces comparateurs
comment on peut les distinguer je vous
dis d'éleveurs d'abord il y en a pas en
fait il faut tous qu'ils ont des
services en france et regroupe entre
autres un comparateur bien établie
depuis neuf ans ils ont un million de
visiteurs par par mois
eux ils ont des services en français
avec bacon aussi évidemment et dans le
cadre de béthune c'est un peu plus qu'un
comparateur c'est un outil qui permet
aussi de faire la gestion de son budget
ses dépenses de son épargne
alors faut voir les options qui sont en
place à surveiller avec keynes une boîte
en forte croissance oui vous avez tout à
fait raison
merci je vous en prie